And they're hungry.
What else is new?
Sure, they're not
little kids anymore,
but they still want
a snack that's fun.
That's why they're not getting
regular old chicken fingers.
They're getting--
(all)
Finger blasted!
(announcer)
Introducing Finger Blasters!
Blast your fingers into
our unique sauce containers,
filled with honey,
tangy barbecue,
or salt and vinegar.
Finger blasting is the best.
Finger blasting
is the perfect thing
to hold them over until
they're ready to move onto
something more serious,
like dinner.
(announcer)
Try one finger at a time.
Yum!
(announcer)
Two fingers.
Mmm, okay!
(announcer)
And then,
if everybody's cool with it,
work up to three!
No, two is good.
For now.
I'll take
what I can get.
(announcer)
Finger blasting
is fun with friends.
But if my friends
aren't around,
I'll just finger blast myself!
"Noice"!
(announcer)
Don't be a food prude!
Surprise the crew by dipping
into two sauces at once.
Whoa.
That's a shocker.
Let's be real.
They're teens.
They're gonna be snacking.
I feel safe knowing
it's under my roof
rather than behind some
movie theater or in the woods.
So get a general sense
of what your kids are putting
in their bodies
and help them--
(all)
Get finger blasted!
(announcer)
Finger Blasters,
from the makers of Circle Jerky.